the whole background of ariel is really
family offices oriented uh you know
multi-generation investors in tech
companies so really people that have a
lot of experience in um
what works and what needs improvement in
the ecosystem and i think that what
drove a reality to become
a new age investment firm
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're
talking about investing but a different
type of investing meet really capital
and specifically or cavill
really capital is a successful venture
capital firm that operates in a very
different model from its industry the
investment model is evergreen not
looking for fast exits it is a
combination of a private equity and a vc
their investors are mostly wealth
management entities and family offices
and they have a unique investment
approach and equity holding structure
with a diverse investment portfolio from
accelerators and ocean tech agrotech to
direct investments in many startups
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for joining me how are you today thank
you for having me mikhail everything is
good and how you feeling these days
i'm feeling good i'm feeling
particularly optimistic because you're
dedicating your career to to working on
very impactful projects for for society
and for the world
not just in the ag tech and ocean tech
and climatetech that that you're working
in in investments but also on you know
in in the cities that you're operating
and the communities that you are that
you're in and i think that it's a that
there's a lot of really interesting
stories to be told here oh tell me a
little bit about yourself your
connection to a lot and then you know
with the could the other connection to
ag tech and and impact technologies okay
so uh first of all it's a pleasure to be
here a great uh hear great things about
your show and i'm happy to be
on board
my name is all
i've been connected to the world of
innovation i think pretty much since i
was born i think it's a passion that i
had since i was a little kid and one of
these kids that loved to
explore never took no for an answer and
you know always wanted to know what's
around the corner and what's coming up
um
and i think that
in around the year 2000 i was i moved to
the silicon valley and i studied
my major in university was the byproduct
of the uh dot-com bubble burst okay
which was basically focusing on the
digital world okay so how does the how
does businesses not brick and mortar
businesses
uh survive thrive grow
and we really got embedded into the
ecosystem and the different components
of the ecosystem back then
you know pretty much um everything we
have on our phone and on our system that
we use uh today was born almost
everything was born there and around
those times so it was very exciting to
be in the valley in those years and to
see all these companies grow
right when you know all the
accelerators and incubators and shared
spaces and meet-ups and all these things
started to happen
and i really one of the first things
that i took from it is the potential of
a community what is the role of an
ecosystem in helping startups grow you
know uh it says there's a famous saying
that it takes a village to grow a child
well
it takes a village to grow a startup
there's a lot of different components
to a healthy ecosystem and i think that
one of the
major changes that i went through in my
life was really being in the valley in
those years and realizing the potential
and the contribution power of an
ecosystem to help growing technology
companies
very very cool talk to me a little bit
about a lot and the you're talking about
ecosystem that it takes a village and
and it sounds like you were you're a
pretty monumental figure and building
that ecosystem and building that village
within the southernmost city of israel
yeah so you know i think the story
of a lot and of different places that
are really operates in is um really a
story of um
building ecosystems and believing in
people and and helping
let's say you know doing our part in
helping to realize human potential um a
really just two seconds about aurelie so
it provides us a little context so
ariely is uh holding an investment uh
firm that uh was founded
around
2016 in new york the it's based in new
york and by uh two
main founders ellie or evan raynov and
eric benthoff and
so the whole background of ariel is
really family offices oriented uh you
know multi-generation investors in tech
companies so really people that have a
lot of experience in um
what works and what needs improvement in
the ecosystem and i think that what
drove a reality to become
a new age investment firm and we all
know the usual uh
models that exist in the ecosystem we
know about the vcs and we know there are
incubators and we know there are um
communities innovation
we have meetups we have events we have
you know many different components in
the ecosystem and really i think what
signifies a really is the fact it's
holistic
atmosphere and holistic overview so the
fact that a reality is not just an
investment firm
but also helps companies to grow and
leads incubators and leads innovation
centers and runs accelerators and works
with academic institutions on academic
commercialization and tto processes
and provides digital services to
companies for digital acceleration which
is a lot of of the downfall a lot of
companies when they scale you know all
these different things provide us with
the ability to look uh in i believe in a
healthy way at uh helping companies grow
and i think that when you take all these
things it really
brings our ability to to help ecosystems
grow and that's also the story like you
mentioned um
in a lot you know a lot is first of all
you know i grew as a as a teenager in a
lot so i have a warm spot in my heart
for a lot you know
warm is a good word when you describe a
lot right so uh we all know you know is
a a lot as a
as a tourist destination a beautiful
place that people go to to vacate well
we saw the the business potential
and um
you know ariely and
a tech center which is our local company
uh
made a beautiful um
beautiful activity there we built a
community and we brought accelerators
you know literally uh for the first time
uh in the history
you had
business accelerators you had uh for
example italian startups you know coming
to a lot to to grow and develop and
close deals which really was you know
the first time up until then you know
people like i said came to a lot for a
vacation or for conventions or things
like that so
we believe in the potential of allah but
also
in other things in the periphery of
israel we all know that most of israel's
high tech scene is centered around tel
aviv and herzeglia and that's where the
majority of the organizations uh and
startups are are at which is which is
good but we all know that if you want to
look at it in a in a sustainable way
it's not sustainable right so you
the country has a lot more to offer uh
and israel's periphery north and south
are
very um are offering a very big variety
of
assets for startups to use i'll give you
a couple of examples
because you asked about it so
in the south obviously obviously you
have the negev right so we all we all
know the negev as a place which is a up
and coming there's a lot of potential
it's a desert it's
about
sixty percent of israel's land mass
so for example one of the things that
ariely has done
is to partner with a ramata negev which
is the largest regional council in the
country about 22 percent of israel's
landmass is under their property
or management
and uh one of the things that they've
done in the past 60 years is to develop
an r d center focusing on agriculture
but on specific type of agriculture
which is bordering desert okay so but we
all know desert you have extreme deserts
like you know the sahara and all that
that's that's one thing but bordering
desert is exactly when
regular climate meets
changing climate or
a
desert climate that's very relevant for
when we talk about globally the climate
change and um you know that the world is
experiencing today
that's relevant for exactly that zone
because that's when you see how for
example grapes certain grapes that are
used to grow in certain areas in the
world they're not used to grow in these
regions where the temperatures are are
extreme and changing all the time
and one of the things that they've done
in their r d center in ramatanega is
really to
find a way to
adopt certain
breeds and certain um
let's call it uh
certain type of crops
to those changing climates that's very
relevant to most places on earth that
are experiencing really that uh that
condition so we we built a frontier from
there is our innovation center focusing
on a desert climate
which has experienced you know a lot of
attention
um you know from companies and investors
and hopefully very soon we'll be able to
announce our up-and-coming incubator and
investment fund that's focusing on
agriculture
which i believe will be very impactful
on on building
or taking that ecosystem of agri-tech
which is very developed in israel i
believe to to really the next level
beautiful
if you're thinking through your
experience now in building villages and
building ecosystems of course
for startups what is something that we
may be overlooking
of the importance of of maybe something
that we take for granted or something
that we don't give enough attention to
but you've through personal experience
you've experienced that wow this is
something that is actually crucial in
building a healthy ecosystem
so that connects me it's a great
question that connects me to a panel i
was invited to speak on an investor
panel from one of our international
partners in tessasan paolo bank which is
one of the largest banking groups in
europe
and the largest one in in italy and in
this panel
one of the final questions was really
what what do you think
is uh
you know one of the key factors um
for for investors when they look at
companies
and one one of the things that i said is
when i look at companies i really also
obviously look at the team i look at the
you know the technology the potential
the market all that stuff but
one of the things that i'm looking at is
where are they
are they in the right place for them are
they in a place where they have a
healthy ecosystem that's going to help
them to grow because like we said it
takes a village and i think a lot of the
things that you know investors sometimes
overlook you know you know being an
investor in the in a tech scene is all
about managing risks okay
and one of the things that i think a lot
of investors sometimes overlook
is
uh to look as a criteria in your risk
assessment specifically
to examine not the company but the
ecosystem and its components where it's
it where it is right now or
maybe it needs to move to a different
one or develop to a different one and
that has a key factor in in helping the
company and that's i'll give you an
example there's a great discussion you
know
will
if if steve jobs would not have been
in the valley
you know in those times will apple still
happen
you know it's it's a great question i
know it's going into the past and asking
you know theoretical questions but
we all know that being in the right
place the right time with the access to
the right services and assets you know
if you're surrounded by
uh um
you know
by scientists and by
uh people with a lot of um you know
digital knowledge and business knowledge
and a lot of an ecosystem that is
healthy also with investors that are
relevant to your sector you know i'll
give you an example one of the things
that reality is developing is an
ecosystem focused on
oceans
ocean technology we all you know there's
a famous i think it's a chinese saying
that says that the the fish is taking
the water
for granted okay i think in essence you
know maybe humanity started to take the
oceans for granted it's about 70 or more
percent of our planet it's it's the
largest you know
body of
something in this world right it affects
everything
that that we talk about that we hear
that that that we feel our climate our
life our food our products you know the
about over 70 80 percent of our products
are shipped and transported
via
you know the oceans in shipping and
trade and logistics and supply chains we
all saw what happened in this industry
lately
when this industry you know had a little
hiccup
it affected prices everywhere in israel
you wanted to you know buy a car you had
to wait for six months or a year to get
it because of that and it affects
everything so
one of the things that really has done
with amazing partners
including you know startups nation
central and and uh universities and
academic and research institutes and
investors etc we built
the first real community that deals with
ocean tech related um
innovations
and we had four events we know focused
on key factors like
the food from the sea the water um the
shipping and trade and logistics the
climate change key things that really
affect all of our lives
uh each event really we saw the demand
because each event attracted you know
hundreds of people from around the world
that came in to listen
what's going on you know what type of
innovation can we can we do to to be
more to protect this valuable resource
so
when we talk about the oceans you know
we spoke up with several israeli
startups
that have amazing technologies for
example for the shipping and logistic
sector and one of the things that these
companies told us is that
when they speak to investors the
investors say listen we know it's an
amazing industry we just don't know
anything about it so we we want to help
you but we can't because we don't
understand the industry so
that's the importance of the ecosystem
you know when you when you're a startup
and you're in the right place that can
help you you know one of the things for
example that we've done in our
ecosystems we had startups that came in
and said okay
how do we meet the first co-founders
so they came to our community and our
community helped them to find their
first programmers and the first
co-founders and then to help them you
know very basic things where do we sit
can we sit down you know startups in the
beginning don't have money to to rent
you know expensive offices and all that
and israel is not really a place where
you have a lot of garages you know in
the valley you had amazing companies
that started in the garages but israel
doesn't really have a lot of garages so
it's it's tough questions of a startup
in the early days where do i sit how do
i meet my co-founders how do i meet my
first programmers these are all answered
by a healthy ecosystem so
i would i would recommend you said what
would i recommend to young entrepreneurs
and actually actually to investors too
is really to look at the company but
also spend a lot of time on thinking are
they
not just with the right product for the
right industry are they in the right
place for them in the right ecosystem
with the right components that's
something that i would really recommend
to start for startups to explore
and sometimes and here's i think one of
the the breaking news
sometimes the right ecosystem for the
startup
is not necessarily tel aviv
okay
just you know explore what type of
assets do you need access to if you need
to research for example the coral reef
because your startup has to do something
with the coral reef
maybe you need to be in a different
ecosystem for part of your startup life
or process so
um
i love it oh
where is this coming from where is all
this passion and this excitement you
know over these last 18 minutes you know
it's very clear how passionate and
excited you are about building these
ecosystems and and building them to
support companies especially that are
doing high impact technologies where is
this coming from
um
first of all i i grew in a house of um
educators you know my mom was a was a
teacher from you know my father
my sister i was surrounded by educators
and one of the things that i saw you
know i saw people
uh
coming to our house with
uh with flowers and gifts you know for
for for my mom and and i asked her all
the time what were these people why
they're bringing all these gifts and
everything
and i learned that these are people that
used to be our students that literally
said that my mom changed their lives and
and send them on a different path and
slowly and surely you know after that i
went to the
i joined the the forces the special
forces uh
in the military and then i was in the
secret service uh for a while and um you
know i saw different aspects of of
humanity and i realized that you know
the most important assets natural asset
that we have
is not gas and it's not you know
diamonds and it's not gold and it's not
the sun or energy or it's
the human brain
it's what exists between our ears right
now anybody that sees and watches this
podcast
you
are the most in you know valuable assets
that this planet maybe the universe has
ever had
we're the only
creature that i know of at least maybe
it'll change soon that can decide one
morning that we want to land
a probe or a
craft on a different planet and we can
execute on it and make it happen i don't
think i mean i mean dolphins are amazing
creatures you know especially we spoke
about a lot a lot is amazing dolphins a
dolphin cannot decide to land itself on
a different planet or to find a cure
within several months for coving or you
know we
have been given
this unbelievable
and and
something that we don't even realize a
um a gift which is the human brain and
are the human potential and that's the
driving force in everything that i do i
promised myself a while ago that
whatever i do i'm going to do different
things but whatever i do i want it to
help
humanity to realize human potential in
my you know small little
impact whatever it's going to be
that's what i want to do
and if i can impact somebody or some
people
i think that's the greatest gift
i think that you know people look at the
sistine chapel you know and
sometimes we know we forget about how it
was made you know and why it was made
and for whom it was made and who paid
for it and all that but that all goes
away because when you're there and you
look at it
you get inspired and i think that that's
one of the greatest thing a person can
achieve in their life is to inspire
a person a different person just inspire
women well all right i want to share
with you
that that i i was left inspired by this
conversation very very much and not just
by the work that you do but but why you
do it and the insights that you have
there and and i think that a lot of
people listening to this will also be
inspired so first of all thank you for
all the amazing work that you've done to
the israel ecosystem but to the world in
general and to people around you and for
the 20 minutes that you've spent here
with me
i really really thank you and it was
really fantastic thank you for coming
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
mikhail for your time and for this
platforming opportunity keep doing this
amazing job and thank you
good luck
thank you very much
you